How did one of the best selling fantasy authors
of the twenty-first century lose the adaptation
opportunity of a lifetime? Just ask The
Kingkiller Chronicle’s Patrick Rothfuss.
Fans of George R.R. Martin's fantasy series A
Song of Ice and Fire know just how torturous it
is to wait for a forthcoming book in a series when
there's no release date in sight. That said, fans
of The Kingkiller Chronicle series might want to
have a word with those desperate Martin readers.
Written by Patrick Rothfuss, The Kingkiller
Chronicle hit shelves in 2007 with its first
installment, The Name of the Wind. Book 2, The
Wise Man's Fear, followed that up in 2011 after
an extended but reasonable delay. However, the
third book, The Doors of Stone, is still nowhere
to be found. As of early 2023, readers have been
waiting for well over a decade for the celebrated
saga to come to a close, with essentially no
information about when that conclusion will come.
In case you're not one of
this series' devoted fans,
The Kingkiller Chronicle is set in the world
of Temerant and told primarily through the main
character's oral history as he recounts
it to a historian known as "chronicler."
The main character, Kvothe might be a
simple innkeeper in the story's present day,
but he was an accomplished wizard and
musician known by many ominous names in
the past. In The Name of the Wind, Kvothe
tells the story of his tragic childhood
and his time spent in cities ravaged by
crime, eventually arriving at a heralded
University where he begins to master a
variety of magical practices. The Wise
Man's Fear follows Kvothe as his education
progresses and he travels to further corners
of the world in his endless pursuit of the
legendary demonic group, the Chandrian.
Between the over 1 million copies of The Name of
the Wind sold, The Wise Man's Fear reaching the
top spot on the New York Times Bestseller list,
and the Game of Thrones-driven fantasy craze of
the mid 2010s, it's not at all surprising
that Hollywood moved fairly quickly to get
an adaptation off the ground. In the summer of
2013, it was reported that a group of writers
and producers had optioned the project, but
the rights expired after a couple of years.
Enter Hamilton scribe and Pulitzer
Prize winner Lin-Manuel Miranda.
As a self-proclaimed megafan of Rothfuss' work,
Miranda was set to produce a TV series based on
The Kingkiller Chronicle. This seemed
to mean only good things for Rothfuss,
as fresh off the mania aroused by Hamilton,
Miranda was the hottest commodity in the industry.
Miranda, who was reportedly also going
to write original music for the series,
was effusive with his praise for The
Kingkiller Chronicle books. He told Vulture,
"I think fans of good writing just like
The Name of the Wind. I had not read a lot
of fantasy books at that point, but I read the
first sentence and I just, I was very drawn in."
Speaking to Entertainment Weekly, Miranda
also said his experience appearing in HBO's
His Dark Materials helped him understand The
Kingkiller Chronicle better. Unfortunately,
the solution for how best to approach the
adaptation eluded even Miranda's sharp mind,
and he left the project in 2022.
Rothfuss has been elusive about the third book
in the promised trilogy for a while — to the
point that many fans doubt the series will ever
reach a conclusion. In fact, his own editor,
Betsy Wollheim, wrote in a Facebook post that she
hadn't read a word of Rothfuss' work in years,
sowing more seeds of doubt about the
trajectory for the book's release.
What's more, as a Reddit user summarized in Summer
2022, Rothfuss also raised money for his charity
by promising to release a new chapter from The
Doors of Stone by February 2022. As of early 2023,
the chapter has yet to materialize and Rothfuss
has yet to make any formal announcements as
to why, which may do some harm to his
credibility in the eyes of producers.
Rothfuss has, however, addressed
his lack of punctuality a few times.
"You can't be more irritated about
not finishing this thing than me,
or my publisher. You got — at
best, you're third in line."
It's worth noting that Rothfuss pretty much
entered the Sci-Fi/Fantasy scene with The Name of
the Wind, and he probably didn't expect his first
two books to blow up as much as they did. Unlike
authors like George R.R. Martin, who has been
writing consistently for decades, Rothfuss doesn't
have the longstanding reputation that might
pacify fans regarding long delays in his writing.
It's also worth acknowledging that
Rothfuss has released two Kingkiller
novellas in the time since The Wise
Man's Fear came out, so fans can rest
assured the universe has not been sitting
stagnantly since the release of book two.
It's likely that after Game of Thrones
outstripped its source material,
Hollywood might be more liable to look
askance at unfinished series. Miranda's
departure may not mark the end of the road for
The Kingkiller Chronicle's Hollywood journey,
but it may be the end until the author
produces a concluding installment.